[Música]
a tecnologia e tudo que ela nos
proporciona é algo fascinante novas
formas de interagir duas formas de lidar
com o próximo
novas formas de viver a tecnologia nos
permite ir além
antigamente nós perpetuavam no nosso
trabalho
escrevendo livros depois passamos a
fazer gravações e posteriormente
criamos vídeos onde podemos ver as
pessoas
o trabalho delas gravadas para a
posteridade
mas agora surge algo novo algo que pode
perpetuar as nossas vidas em vários
aspectos
a inteligência artificial para falar
sobre inteligência artificial num sobre
os fundamentos dela eu tive um contato
muito interessante com um especialista
durante um ano
em 2010 a 2011 eu tive um contato muito
forte com o especialista o nome dele é
daniel
ele esteve diante de um mundo de
possibilidades
ele percebeu o universo ao meu redor
dele ea primeira reação dele foi assim
que pensou assim altíssima por favor me
ajuda aqui é mais embaixo
depois de um tempo o daniel teve uma
iluminação
ele se preparou se formou e quando já
estava maduro
cinco anos depois ele já estava apto a
lidar com o mundo de possibilidades que
estavam ao redor dele
ele percebeu que vivia num mundo onde
existir uma camada real e uma camada
virtual e começou a integrar aquilo que
ele sonhava aquilo que ele pensava a
respeito da sociedade o dobro do que ele
vive ao redor dele em uma forma de
interação lúdica
há de tudo o que acontecia sozinho ele
encontrou aplicativos e sozinho ele
começou a interagir com as
possibilidades e começou a criar vídeos
ea partir daí a brincadeira que ele
fazia passou a ser perpetuada na
internet
além disso ele começou a perceber que
essa forma lúdica interessava as outras
crianças ao redor dele pois é num no
final sempre acaba bem ali alguém vai lá
resgatar pessoas em prover com isso
acontece
o cara veio bom de roteiro o grande x
aqui o que o daniel fez uma parte do que
todos nós estamos fazendo nosso dia a
dia
todos nós estamos produzindo de alguma
forma conteúdo
esse conteúdo ele vai nos levar a uma
situação de ruptura
a situação de ruptura vai ser baseada em
tudo que produzimos desde imagens sons
vídeos compartilhamento em redes sociais
tudo que nós podemos agora usufruir
dessa super máquinas que temos em nossas
mãos
essas máquinas são capazes de lidar com
aspectos de inteligência artificial e
podem ser potencializados por nós mesmos
todo o tempo quando pensamos na evolução
do fluxo de informações na internet
percebemos que a tendência disso é uma
explosão alavancadora se imaginarmos um
pouco mais nos últimos dois anos nós
duplicamos todo o volume de dados e
conhecimentos que a humanidade produziu
a tendência até 2020
chegamos a um valor astronômico de 44
zeta bytes de informação
quem pode lidar com tudo isso quem pode
conduzir a análises sobre essa
volumetria de dados que tende a crescer
cronicamente principalmente quando os
sírios entrar em operação
pensando nisso podemos imaginar que mais
informações e os dados estão sendo
coletados
ao analisarmos por exemplo os dados de
um paciente de câncer o câncer é
descrito como uma das quatro piores
doenças que afetam a humanidade
um paciente de câncer gerem se um
terabyte de informações por dia ou seja
adquiridos nós que o nosso melhor
computador que está à venda nas lojas
têm no máximo 1 terabyte de memória
conseguiria trabalhar e lidar com
somente os dados de um dia de um
paciente de câncer
pensando nesse contexto começamos a usar
algoritmos de inteligência artificial
máquinas de aprendizado e começamos a
capturar todos os tipos de informações
que temos no nosso dia a dia
mesmo que não queiramos fazer isso todos
eletrônicos que possuímos vão fazer isso
pra nós sabemos o quanto andamos sabemos
se corrermos ou não e tudo isso alimenta
bases para a tomada de decisão
dizem que nós vivemos uma época chamada
de big data
eu diria que nós estamos molhando os pés
e que nos próximos dez anos nós vamos
realmente mergulhar num oceano de dados
no infinito céu de possibilidades mas
como nós vamos lidar com tudo isso da
nossa capacidade de memória de
armazenamento de processamento biológica
então pra isso começamos a trabalhar com
a inteligência artificial em 1956 de uma
carta definiu a inteligência artificial
com uma ciência e engenharia de produzir
máquinas inteligentes percebam que a
máquina inteligente naquela época não
era um robô é um algoritmo era um
artefato lógico que pudesse ser
inteligente a ponto de resolver um
problema
a ideia da inteligência artificial nesse
caso é analisar aquela multidão de dados
simplificar todas essas informações e
fornecer para nós uma forma um caminho
da gente obter sucesso no que a gente
quer
quando pensamos nisso aplicando isso
para o nosso dia-a-dia começamos a
desafiar essa proposição e o primeiro
desafio foi criamos super máquinas
a ibm criou um computador chamado de
blue e colocou à prova com o maior
mestre de xadrez a problemática naquele
momento era entender as probabilidades
matemáticas de uma máquina de tomar a
melhor decisão
já sabemos o final da história então em
1996 tivemos uma máquina que vencer um
grande jogador de xadrez
o maior jogador de xadrez da história
mas a inteligência artificial
tinha que avançar e ela tinha que
avançar para outros contextos
com textos que nos pudesse fazer
entender a linguagem humana que pudesse
nos fazer entender as idéias que estavam
sendo propagadas nesse universo de dados
ao fazermos isso começamos a tocar num
ponto muito importante que é como nós
entendemos o nosso trabalho como nós
entendemos a nossa cidade
partimos então a entrar em cada um dos
campos do conhecimento sejam eles a
discutir na áreas sejam eles uma área
específica muito como rh sejam eles na
parte específica como direito e todo o
contexto de vocabulário e conhecimento
desenvolvido para cada uma dessas áreas
passou a ser alvo de desenvolvimento
dessa inteligência artificial
essa inteligência artificial começa a
trabalhar a volumetria de dados que
existe e começa a trazer conhecimento
sobre cada uma dessas áreas
potencializando as pessoas que atuam em
cada uma delas
com esse conhecimento surgiu um novo
desafio enfrentar o ser humano num jogo
de perguntas e respostas dado um
conteúdo limitado e vencê lo ou seja
entendendo as perguntas falar
a resposta mais adequada da mesma forma
o melhor que o ser humano em 2011 foi
possível e o ambiente bb robson ganhou
dos melhores jogadores de o porte do
mundo
nesse momento em 2011 começávamos a
demonstrar que a inteligência artificial
passou a entender o conteúdo um pouco
das idéias e os conceitos da humanidade
mas não parou por aí surgiram desafios
mais amplos mais difíceis então pra
esses novos desafios
começamos a utilizar um conjunto de
conhecimentos chamados de de planing
aprendizagem profunda ao invés de
ficarmos treinando matematicamente
puramente fazendo equações colocamos e
sensibilizamos equipamentos ea partir
daí conforme nós operávamos uma
determinada situação
o sistema prendia e começava a tomar as
melhores decisões
começamos a criar ambientes que
aprendiam como ganhar jogos sozinho eo
grande desafio quando a gente pensa em
jogos só que é uma uma exemplo de uma
rede neural uma rede de aprendizado
reforçado onde você sensores o ambiente
ele vai aprendendo em tempo real
o grande desafio de jogos era um famoso
jogo go ea empresa de permanentes
desenvolveu um algoritmo poderoso para
combater um jogo que é extremamente
complexo de forma a trazer
possibilidades de vencer o campeão de go
nesse momento usando de plano usando um
conjunto de algoritmos e técnicas
avançados
essa empresa venceu um jogo super
complexo que era o gol ao fazer isso
se vale de um conjunto de elementos para
a tomada de decisão e esse conjunto de
elementos consiste em usar a
inteligência artificial para aprender a
construir para compreender o ambiente
para capturar o expertise e até ensinar
para ajudar a obter sucesso
sei que muitos de vocês têm concepções
sobre onde a inteligência artificial
pode nos levar
ela pode nos levar à ruína ou ela pode
nos levar a marte
depende do que vamos fazer com essas com
percepções
ao fazermos isso devemos entender como a
inteligência artificial entende o
problema então inicialmente ele executa
as mesmas tarefas que o ser humano faz
ela sul marisa um problema ela resume
uma questão
depois ela segmenta o público ou
segmento a situação ela pode ser usada
para a classificação de clientes
ela pode ser usada para estimar quanto
tempo demoraremos para chegar num lugar
ela pode ser usada para prevermos como
estaremos daqui a dois anos
ela pode ser usada para a recomendação
de produtos para iluminação de qualquer
tipo de situação que temos é o de
serviço então as inteligências
artificiais elas partem das simples
execução de tarefas que nós fazemos
nosso dia a dia
ao chegarmos em uma festa a primeira
coisa que a gente faz é olhar o ambiente
e verificar se tem comida boa e sem
comida suficiente pra todo mundo né
então para alguns pode ser diferente a
demanda né
depois nós podemos segmentar que quantas
pessoas têm desse tipo aqui na festa
quantas da outra e assim em diante ou
seja tarefas humanas que a inteligência
artificial passa a aprender ea realizar
fazendo isso partimos para um outro
contexto todo tipo de informação serve
agora para gerar o que a gente chama de
insight descobrindo dentro de grandes
bases de dados que são as que você já
eram possíveis informações valiosas para
as empresas
vocês ou para os pesquisadores tendo em
fato esse conjunto de informação
começamos uma nova parceria
uma parceria entre homens e máquinas
o fato é que hoje nós temos a tecnologia
tão avançada tão próxima de nós que nós
podemos dizer que somos quase 1 com ela
em alguns aspectos
os sistemas cognitivos ajudam a eliminar
vieses revés o viés do racismo o viés do
preconceito o viés do que não é legal da
humanidade
a preferência já o sistema o ambiente
humano o ser humano sempre vai ter sobre
si a responsabilidade da moral do senso
comum da compaixão coisas que podemos
até ensinar para uma máquina mas que ela
nunca vai realmente entender porque ela
faz aqui juntos então conseguimos
construir um novo universo
esse novo universo já está sendo
aplicado na saúde
todos os anos 100 mil estudos sobre o
câncer são lançados que médico que
consegue ler 100 mil estudos no ano
mas essas inteligências artificiais
conseguem ler isso no brasil já temos um
grande hospital no sul se valendo dessa
tecnologia no tratamento do câncer
também mais de meio milhão de pessoas já
fizeram um mapeamento genômico e esses
dados são recebidas por essa tecnologia
e servem para perpetuar o contexto das
nossas vidas
caso não saibam a cada ano que se passa
nós temos uma perspectiva de ganharmos
mais três meses de vida
ou seja depois de 40 anos
quem viver 40 anos provavelmente vai ter
mais dez anos a expectativa de vida
aumentada em função da inteligência
artificial aplicada também podemos usar
isso
estão dos comportamentos dessa
inteligência artificial consegue
analisar personalidade conseguem
detectar gostos de ações consegue ser o
nosso amigo na hora que precisamos
o grande x é que com tudo isso nós
também percebemos que no mercado
tudo muda empresas tradicionais são
desafiados por empresas que acabaram de
surgir que mesclam o aspecto tecnológico
e inteligência artificial embutida na
oferta de seus produtos ou na seleção do
que está sendo trabalhado com isso
podemos também nos valer de outros
contextos tecnológicos dessas
inteligências artificiais passam a se
valer também de recursos tecnológicos
como chips euro sinápticos em 2011 nós
tínhamos essa realidade onde trabalho
já temos uma realidade de podemos
trabalhar com mais de um milhão de
neurônios programáveis é uma nova
abordagem é um novo contexto e esse novo
contexto chega impactam no nosso
trabalho
quem aí não tem medo do que vai ser o
nosso trabalho no futuro
nós sabemos que nos próximos dez anos o
que nós fazemos hoje não será o que nós
faremos amanhã
então nós vamos ter dois tipos de visão
do contexto de trabalho um grupo focado
empoderamento tecnológico de ambientes
de ei diabo construtores de inteligência
artificial meu trabalho de cientistas de
dados não existia há seis anos atrás
ele é novo e surgem novos trabalhos como
engenheiros de máquinas de aprendizado
como pessoas que vão trabalhar com
textos de tecnologia oficial na nuvem
por outro lado nós vamos ter pessoas que
vão valer se dessa inteligência
artificial pessoas que vão ser blogueiro
pessoas que vão lidar com marketing
digital pessoas das mais variadas
o grande x é que todas esses trabalhos e
todas as pessoas em qualquer uma das
profissões
pode se valer do poder da inteligência
artificial ao treinar uma inteligência
artificial
você não está perpetuando simplesmente a
sua existência atual do contexto de ter
um trabalho melhor
mas você está perpetuando as suas ideias
e potencializando um futuro melhor para
a humanidade
adriano
[Aplausos]